estoy animado por mejorar mi
flexibilidad corporal por lo cual he
decidido tomar unas clases de yoga me
presenté al lugar de las clases de yoga
llamado super yoga y les pregunté cuánto
cuesta las clases a lo cual me
respondieron tenemos el plan básico y el
plan de prueba en el plan de prueba tú
puedes venir a probar las clases por lo
cual te va a costar 12 dólares por
sesión de una hora pero si te gustan las
clases puedes adquirir una membresía
mensual pagarías 20 dólares por mes en
lo que se llama el plan básico son 20
dólares por mes y tienes un descuento
por sesión sólo pagas 8 dólares por
sesión esto me parece interesante pero
estoy un poco confundido cuál es el plan
que me conviene para ver esto yo
empezaría preguntándome cuánto pagaría
de acuerdo a cada plan según el número
de sesiones que voy a tomar y para
facilitar este trabajo vamos a definir
algunas variables
llamémosle ese al número de sesiones que
voy a asistir mensualmente al número de
sesiones
por mes el número de sesiones a las que
asistir e mensualmente en super yoga
digamos que ese es el costo mensual
total el costo mensual total así es que
con estas variables así definidas veamos
cuánto me costará cada uno de los planes
dependiendo del número de sesiones que
voy a tomar lo que aquí vamos a hacer es
voy a empezar con el plan de prueba se
ve más simple este plan de prueba para
esto voy a hacer una tabla con el costo
no voy a empezar la tabla mejor con el
número de sesiones
el costo para ese número de sesiones
esta sería nuestra pequeña tabla para el
plan de prueba y también voy a hacer una
pequeña tabla para el plan básico dado
que queremos comparar ambos planes el
plan básico y el plan de prueba nuestra
tabla para el plan básico también
incluiría el número de sesiones y el
costo total correspondiente a ese número
de sesiones pensemos entonces qué pasa
para empezar si decido no asistir a
ninguna sesión si decido asistir a cero
sesiones en el plan de prueba cuál será
el costo bien doce dólares por sesión 12
dólares por 0 sesiones no voy a tener
que pagar nada el costo total va a ser
cero ahora qué pasa con la misma
situación en el plan básico si tengo el
plan básico y en un mes dado no asisto a
ninguna sesión no asisto al estudio no
asisto al estudio superior a para nada
cuánto entonces voy a pagar son ocho
dólares por sesión pero no fui a ninguna
sesión así es que no voy a pagar nada
por el costo de sesión pero si tengo que
pagar
los 20 dólares por mes así es que si voy
a pagar 20 dólares aunque no haya
asistido a ninguna sesión esta opción
realmente no es atractiva bajo el plan
básico veamos otras opciones
consideremos ahora la opción en que
asisto a una sesión la opción de que
asiste una sesión bajo el plan de prueba
son 12 dólares por sesión serían 12
dólares por sesión por una sesión
eso sería 12 dólares los que pagaría al
mes por una sesión en el plan de prueba
qué pasa con el plan básico con el plan
básico por una sesión con el plan básico
por una sesión pagaría 8 dólares por
sesión por una sesión serían 8 dólares
más la cuota fija de 20 dólares al mes
así es que sería 20 + 828 dólares al mes
que pagaría por una sesión con el plan
básico aún sigue siendo más conveniente
el plan de prueba asistiendo a tan sólo
una sesión así es que esto es 20 dólares
y aquí tenemos 28 dólares y podría
seguir con estas tablas
de hecho te invito a que lo hagas que
siga llenando estas tablas para que
percibes cómo se van dando los números
si asisto a dos sesiones con el plan de
prueba tendría que pagar 12 por sesión
por dos sesiones pagaría 24 dólares en
cambio en el plan básico si yo asisto a
dos sesiones lo voy a hacer en amarillo
si asisto a dos sesiones pagaría ocho
dólares por sesión ocho por dos más
veinte dólares del pago mensual es decir
pagaría vamos a desglosar el pago
pagaría dos por ocho más el pago mensual
de 20 dólares esto es igual 2 por 8 16 +
20 36 dólares es lo que pagaría así es
que al menos para cero uno o dos
sesiones que tenemos aquí el plan de
prueba sigue siendo el más conveniente
lo que quiero hacer es encontrar en qué
punto es más conveniente el plan básico
que el plan de prueba pero antes de
hacer eso veamos si podemos representar
esto de una manera más algebraica
es lo que nos va a permitir responder de
manera precisa a nuestras preguntas si
consideramos que ese es el número de
sesiones por mes ese es el costo mensual
cómo podemos representar el plan de
prueba con una ecuación bueno nuestro
costo mensual total nuestro costo
mensual total se y esto es para el plan
de prueba deja de poner aquí una línea
punteada una línea punteada para separar
el plan de prueba nuestro costo total
mensual va a ser igual a 12 dólares por
sesión es decir 12 que multiplica a el
número de sesiones que es ese 12 por s
así es que para el plan de prueba puede
establecer que el costo total mensual es
igual a 12 dólares por el número de
sesiones o 12 dólares por sesión por el
número de sesiones hagamos lo mismo para
el plan básico como podemos expresar
esto con una ecuación tenemos que
nuestro costo total mensual que hemos
llamado c esto va a ser igual a bueno
sin importar lo que hagamos vamos a
tener que pagar 20 dólares por mes sin
importar si tomamos sesión
eso no tenemos que pagar 20 dólares por
mes es decir ese costo total va a ser
igual a 20 al cual le vamos a sumar 8
dólares por sesión 20 del costo mensual
fijo más 8 dólares que tenemos que pagar
por cada sesión es decir 20 más 8 por el
número de sesiones s 20 más 8 ese y
podemos verificar que si tenemos 0
sesiones tendríamos 0 aquí y el
resultado sería 20 más 8 por 0 20
dólares si tenemos una sesión ese sería
uno 20 más 8 por 128 dólares
podemos ver entonces que estos valores
de s se cumplen con la ecuación lo mismo
pasa aquí podríamos inclusive generar
más valores lo que es realmente
extraordinario de estas ecuaciones esta
simple ecuación describe todas las
opciones que tenemos aquí y esta simple
ecuación comprende describe abarca todas
las opciones que tenemos aquí en los
siguientes vídeos lo que voy a hacer es
explorar cómo podemos usar estas dos
ecuaciones para darme claridad
acerca de cuál es el plan más
conveniente